bon ça
ça vous aimez ah bon jamais dans ses
très bons oui c'est peu dire pour amener
un peu de deux périodes bail à vaincre
au dos aujourd'hui oui j'ai des gros dos
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous savez chaque
semaine on commence avec baba sacko
depuis seconde in the grass et force est
formel à nikos est parti en vacances
dans non c'est pas nikos c'est jean-luc
salut
salut tu as alors dit en fait jean luc
reichmann mais quand il est honni quand
il étonné alors j'ai craqué et la
césarienne est un candidat jean-luc
attention attention bienvenue dans les
mousses coup à 2008
salah le public
le soleil
le soleil bienvenu je suis avec roger
bonjour jai bonjour je
vous avais dit anecdote c'est tout mais
ce que je suis boulanger
du port
entre autres de la baguette
non tu me réveille chez tous et pour
aller faire le buzz est ce que c'est
vrai que les premiers clients arrivent
très tôt donc un jour je me réveille à
3h30 un 3e nuit
oui et en fait je marque 4 3 est en fait
un jour j'avais mis mon réveil à 3h30
mais de l'après-midi cause beaucoup subi
mais c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]
et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui douze coups de minuit entre prochain
candidat nous vient de clermont ferrand
oui oui tout va bien c'est oui c'est
vrai que je suis avec donc christophe
salut christophe pourcel vous avez 35
ans oui sauf raconté ou ce qui s'est
passé avec votre ex alors avec mon ex
est très simple j'étais avec une jeune
fille voilà pendant quelques années que
savourer
delphine minoui est en fait un jour elle
me dit allons restons au restaurant oui
du coup s'il doit me donner au bond et l
anneau et les restaurants asiatiques
asiatiques et là on embrasse les nems
oui je me demande à patates impérial et
qu'est ce qui m'amène qu'est ce qui vous
a mené à pâté de fou c'était
[Applaudissements]
notre
humilité donc
ses amis dans le métier
tu vois ça me fait du bien et oui le
soleil brille